Why Engines are Commonly Measured in Horsepower
We owe the “horsepower” unit of engine
power measurement to Scottish engineer James
Watt.
In the early 1780s, after making a vastly
superior steam engine to the then classic
Newcomen steam engine, Watt was looking for
a way to market his invention, advertising
the fact that his engine used about 75% less
fuel than a similarly powered Newcomen, among
many other improvements.
At first, he tried selling his engine on a
royalty scheme, where the customers would
owe him one-third of the money they saved
by using his engine over other steam engines.
Of course, many at the time used horses, not
steam engines, so it was difficult to compare
without them actually buying the engine to
see how it would perform for their particular
usage.
Thus, he scrapped the royalty scheme and decided
to try a different tact to convince people
to buy his engine.
Ever the inventor, his solution was to come
up with a new unit of measurement that those
in need of his engine understood -horse power,
referring to powerful draft horses.
Thus, he set about determining how much power
a typical draft horse could generate.
It isn’t known exactly how he came up with
the numbers he did, as there are conflicting
accounts of the experiments he ran.
But after doing those experiments, he figured
out a typical draft horse could do about 32,400
foot-pounds of work in 60 seconds and maintain
that power rate for a good long workday.
He then rounded up, going with 33,000 foot-pounds
per minute for 1 horsepower.
So, in other words, by his estimation a good
draft horse could lift 33,000 pounds of material
1 foot in 1 minute or 3,300 pounds of material
10 feet in one minute, etc .
In truth, that’s a very generous estimate
as very few horses could maintain that kind
of power for a full workday, but getting a
perfect figure wasn’t that important to
what Watt was trying to do.
Further, by overestimating what a horse could
do, whether intentionally or not, he made
sure that his product would always over deliver
what he said when trying to get people to
buy it, which is a great word-of-mouth marketing
trick.
In the end, Watt’s engine was revolutionary
and played a huge role in the Industrial Revolution.
Thanks to this fact, his unit of measure of
an engine’s power, horsepower, also became
popular.
Funny enough, today the SI unit of power,
the Watt, which was named in homage to James
Watt, has widely come to replace “horsepower”
in most applications.
Bonus Fact:
While Watt came up with the exact measurement
of what would become “horsepower,” he
was not the first to propose the idea of equating
a steam engine’s power to a horse’s.
The first documented instance of this was
suggested by British inventor Thomas Savery
who wrote the following in a letter in 1702:
“So that an engine which will raise as much
water as two horses, working together at one
time in such a work, can do, and for which
there must be constantly kept ten or twelve
horses for doing the same.
Then I say, such an engine may be made large
enough to do the work required in employing
eight, ten, fifteen, or twenty horses to be
constantly maintained and kept for doing such
a work…”